they need someone to look out for them
and I fathered them so it's my
responsibility so you're telling me that
your purpose on earth is to look out for
like a superhero 533 children
I didn't say superhero I have curiosity
when you're looking out these children
we'd be wearing any kind of cape I
didn't say superhero I said guardian
angels
so no cape but you will have wings and
play the harp you know I'm starting to
feel more and more comfortable with this
insanity plea I do not have mental
problems Junction right that's all out
there he's waving his arm around and
everything
he's gonna be a good boy and take a dive
like patty said you would I'm not gonna
have to teach you a lesson
no he's good he's good he's me lesson I
gave you our word yeah teach you your
lesson everything's good
let me hear you say I'm an opportunity
they just have to be brave enough to
take it we have to go gale before they
kill us they will kill us
what about the other families huh the
ones who stay what happens to them
people are looking at you cat I don't
want anyone looking to me I can't help
them
you almost set me on fire you don't tell
them what to do